breaking about PPE and an announcement
by the Department of Health and the
Health and Safety Executive basically
saying they're changing the advice on
PPE saying it is now okay to reuse
equipment even where it is designated
single-use by manufacturers it says some
compromised in the process is needed to
optimize supply in times of extreme
shortages then says that the advice is -
in the absence of a full-length gown is
to use any other full-length garment
garments or specific full-length
garments with an apron a protective
apron over the top of that and this is
at the Guardians reporting that the
supply of gowns could run out within
hours let's go to our deputy political
editor Sam coats and Sam I have to say
quite surprised that that wasn't raised
in the news conference there but this
statement from the Department of Health
does come as the Guardian issued a story
about the supply of gowns yes I think it
took until the expressin star at the end
to raise this issue of the shortage of
PPE Alok Sharma will probably be quite
relieved that he didn't come under more
pressure on the subject when he was
asked about this extraordinary alert
that's gone out across the NHS about a
short of an impending shortage of PPE
the government effectively confirming
that there's a shortage of PPE he simply
said that there's a global shortage just
as a problem worldwide we need to be on
top of it and we need to produce more
and many effects more manufacturing more
and procure more that broad-brush answer
really not quite matching the
extraordinary nature of the announcement
made at about 10:00 to 5:00 just before
the press conference coming about five
minutes after the Guardian published a
story along a similar theme basically
first of all admitting that there is a
shortage of PPE going into this weekend
something that Matt Hancock didn't
appear to do in front of a select
committee this morning even though
perhaps you would have thought he might
have known and then going through deal
recommended alternatives that nurses and
doctors should consider this weekend and
you read some of the key sections of the
document saying that the guidance is
changing when there is a shortage of the
necessary equipment I mean some of the
language in this document is quite
striking it does say at one point what
that you should start considering
reusable gowns rather rather than
disposable gowns and coveralls you
should shift to reusable options and it
gives you enough that gives doctors and
nurses the kind of alternative equipment
that they should start thinking about
using this weekend so if there are no
disposable gowns you should use reusable
gowns reusable laboratory coats reusable
long sleeved patient gowns and reusable
coveralls so it does seem as if they're
encouraging doctors and nurses to sort
of go through the cupboards really this
weekend to try and find alternatives the
problem is that although the government
has delivered a billion pieces of PPE
personal protective equipment over the
last few weeks to deal with the
coronavirus crisis you get through it as
an incredible rate as people use it and
then have to dispose of it for a fear of
infection and a lot of the PPE does
actually come from China but there is a
global demand on this because every
country is facing the same problem at
the same time I spoke earlier this week
to one one person who distributes
personal protective equipment who said
that they can't get space on containers
from China - which can contain which can
carry PPE over to the UK for love nor
money because of the worldwide shortage
so this problem does look as if it could
potentially get worse and there isn't a
huge amount of capacity to manufacture
PPE in the UK and it does appear as if
for the first time with this alert
that's gone out to the NHS this evening
that the government formally confirming
that there are going to be shortages and
then having to recommend alternatives
lower standards effectively that doctors
and nurses will have to adhere to when
they are treating patients in order to
be safe